diversification is really all about how
much you have to lose this is what i
think a lot of people make a mistake on
diversification if you've got a lot to
lose if you've got a lot of money in
your business if you've got a lot of
money in real estate or the stock market
if you've got something to lose
then you need to start to think about
diversification because something could
go wrong and destroy
that stock market destroy that business
and you need to start diversifying but
if you have nothing to lose this is
another huge mistake that a lot of
entrepreneurs make if you've got nothing
to lose
diversification is is a terrible
strategy it's not going to help you it's
not going to work
the number of entrepreneurs who
dm me and say hey i'm setting up my 14
different streams of income meanwhile
none of them are working it's a fatal
mistake so many people make is there's a
lack of focus at the beginning because
you're trying to diversify too soon too
quickly when you've got nothing to lose